hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
on cd4 chameric antigen receptors to
redi
direct cd4 t cells to target hiv
infection i am lisa burkey from nexulum
bioscience where we have a team of
experts in the science of cell counting
and cell-based assays
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i am excited to present our first
speaker dr james reilly
who is a professor of microbiology at
the university of pennsylvania
for a complete biography on dr riley
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr reilly you may now begin your
presentation
somehow andrea's slides are appearing in
front of me
you get it from my sides up here
hello
uh
hello could anybody hear me dr riley
there's a tab
at the top of your screen for your
presentation
got it thank you
okay um uh hello everybody um
uh just wanna before i get into the talk
share uh a disclosure
um in which some of the technologies
i'll speak about today has been licensed
to community
uh so um back in the 90s
uh we developed a series of anti-viral
drugs
and the hope would be is that we would
be able to cure hiv at that point once
we were able
to stop all the uh replication
um and there
this chart here shows the um
you know the q phase and the loss of t
cells
um and then what generally happened
patients go on
and then this leads to um
a loss of t cells over time but
the problem that happened was is
um there's a laden reservoir
generated by hiv and no matter how much
art we give
to people this reservoir continues and
it
doesn't you know while it does have a
slow half-life
it nobody would ever be cured of hiv for
light on this
and so the focus of the field is to
how can we get rid of this latent
reservoir and one strategy that's been
put
forth is it's called a kick and kill
strategy
in which some agents is called the
latency reversal agent
um is is given to a person and what this
um agent does is that it uh provides
enough of a stimulus
to the t cell or to the cell harvard in
the hiv
to initiating birth to transcription
of hiv transcription and then that would
then enable the immune system
to recognize the cell and hopefully uh
remove it
and while this is an elegant idea um
it's it hasn't worked terribly well
one the the latency reversal agents are
not
universally effective so they only
target maybe a fraction of the cells
that harbor hiv
and uh at the time that these are
administered the
hiv specific immune system is in bad
shape
uh energy has been largely away so the
memory response is greatly attenuated
and the cells are remaining or
exhausted and they recognize
escape nutrients that really aren't
present so
um there's a need then to
sort of rebuild the hiv specimen
response
before we do these types of kick and
kill
strategies and so the argument i'd like
to make
is you know instead of using the natural
immune system
we're now at the point now where an
engineered immune system
would be perhaps more desirable and the
example i like to use
is robocop so robocop
was a movie that um in which a very good
cop
was uh you know patrolling the streets
of detroit
and a bad guy came in and he got hurt
really badly
but instead of just restoring alex
murphy back to where he was
uh the city and the company decided
let's make him so that the next time he
sees his gang
he'll be able then to defeat it and so
they gave him some armor
as well as a a very potent weapon
by which he could then control this gang
and i think the hiv
uh immune response is very um could be
very similar to this
uh initially um the hiv response is like
alice murphy where it really gets
decimated by hiv
and so what we propose then is can we
make it make a robocop version
of the hiv revised which will hopefully
be able to work much better than it did
the first time
and so one of the initial efforts of
this uh was a study
uh that our center conducted looking at
the ability to seek finger nucleases
to make uh cd4 cells hiv resistant
um and for the sake of time we'll go
through this very quickly
but you know this isn't like uh what
some of you may have heard
you know uh where people receive a bone
marrow transplant containing ccr
deficient bone marrow and that results
in a cure
there every cell in the person at least
every immune cell
is ccr5 negative in this particular case
we're only putting a fraction of the
cells back in and so we're not really
limiting the spread of the virus
but what we're hopefully doing is arming
at least a part of the immune system
so that would be hiv resistant and
the results of this trial were really
quite interesting
so the people receive the cells
and then um were to say what's called
the analytical treatment eruption which
they stopped taking their medicine
and then we observed that you know how
quickly the virus rebounded
and in general the virus rebounded
pretty typically to what you see there
might be a slight delay
but in most of the patients you can see
once they reached its peak
there was a subsequent drop
in the viral load and you know
and they continue down that one patient
here actually
went and then kind of went all the way
down before we had to start
therapy again and so this gave us a
sense that maybe there is some
dominant immune response going on so we
followed this up with a with a sort of a
separate
clinical trial um in which we
um you know did a few
digital things that i can't go into but
we tried to increase the graphing by
uh some cytotoxin um
and we also enrolled a number of
delta 32 uh individuals these are people
that already have one
mutant allele of ccr5 because that would
enhance them the number of cells that
were actually doubly deficient
and as again what i showed you before if
we just look to the time when the virus
rebounds
compared to a very similar cohort we see
a slight delay
but it's you know maybe a couple weeks
so it's nothing to really write home
about
but what got us interested in this study
more
interesting i should say there are a
number of patients that are highlighted
in this red here that were able to stay
in a very
long ati
so the criteria that we had is that you
had to have a viral load over a hundred
thousand for three
consecutive time none of these patients
you know
got there in 16 weeks uh and the way we
wrote the protocol is that they had the
option to continue their ati
as long as they kept their viral load
under a thousand
um and you can see three of these people
you know this individual right here
almost kept it out
a whole year um and so
we were interested in studying these
patients to really try to understand
how were they able to maintain this low
viral load
and we looked at the hiv specific immune
responses
um now only in these three patients did
we see
sort of a restoration of the hiv
specific
response you can see that in this
particular case here
there's quite a profound expansion of
this response considering we're
you know as saying the entire cba
repertoire here
um so you know 1.4 of the entire
repertoire is able to see this
particular
and then to lesser extents we saw a
restoration of other responses in these
things
whereas in the other patients there's a
few here or there but nothing really
dramatic as we saw in these three
patients that were able to
maintain control and then in one of the
patients we were able then to really map
the exact epitope that was expanded uh
here and then sequence the patient virus
before the therapy
after the therapy and what you can see
is that at least one of these
individuals
a full escape mutant was emerged
that you know converted this into a
non-recognizable epitope so it suggests
that the
immunological pressure that was put was
strong enough
that hiv actually had to mutate in order
to
start replicating again and so you know
what this gave us hope is is that yes
the immune system can be trained
to control hiv uh but this particular
trial was
you know only really uh at the very
beginning where only us
a small fraction of cd4 cells were hiv
resistant
and it's unclear how many of those cd4
cells are actually hiv specific
so the hypothesis that carries us to the
next study is well what if they used
chimeric antigen
uh receptor therapy it made all the all
the cd4 cells
now hiv specific
um and so i'll show you next the
pre-clinical studies
that have now led to us testing this in
the clinic
and so as a brief introduction a
chameric engine receptor
is a different way to direct t cells
towards the target
so in this particular case and it gets a
little confusing so i'll walk you
through it
um we're outputting the cd4 molecule
as the um sort of the bait for hiv
because cd4 is the natural receptor
for hiv envelope and the reason we do
that
is because um it
makes it hard for hiv to escape because
if hiv can't bind to cd4
then it's gonna be hard for it to get
around that um
but we're putting these cd4 cars into
cd4
t-cells so work with me as like as i
actually tried to explain that
um and then after the cd4
targeting mode there we have a 401 b or
number of customatory molecule and then
coupled to the
signal one to stevie three uh champ
um and
a study that we did um you know prior to
this using cda t
cells we were able to show in this
humanized mouse model
that we were able to you know
significantly reduce the amount of virus
that emerged
after analytical uh treatment
interruption compared to controlled
cells
so we wanted to see could um
the same activity exist in cd4 t
cells and so um a great student kobe
badini
took this and the first thing we did was
we hooked up a variety of different
constimatory molecules
uh so um this is cb28
ipos ox4b 401b and cd27
he linked all these to a gfp marker so
you could see
both the car and the gfp uh expression
levels
um and then we he did a um
a mixing so we took these cells and
mixed them with
uh k562 cell that express hiv envelope
and then track the ability of the t
cells to make cytokines and what you can
see is that there is some heterogeneity
uh regarding how the constitutory
molecule affects t cell
function for example this 401 b molecule
makes much less cytokines relative to
a cd28 molecule
that makes many more cytokines and this
is consistent to what we saw
with cva t cells
the question we had is well kncd4
cells can they actually control the
replication of hiv so here we took those
cells i just described to you
and we mix them at these ratios
with uh infected cd4 t
cells and ask can they stop the spread
of the infection so if we mix it
untransduced t
cells you can see you know this is a
particular time point day eight
we can see you see that there's quite a
bit of hiv infection present
um with the car t cells you can see
at various rates you know 150 we see
mostly control
but as we lower the effect of the target
ratio
um we see some hair genetic depending on
the stimulatory molecule
you see here that the cd28 and the c3
zeta
control the hiv replication the best
whereas cd27 ox 40 on down
actually uh are worse than
the cd-3 data alone signal
we are interested in understanding the
mechanism by which cb4t
cells could suppress hiv replication
so in this particular assay colby
super lego got really infected uh cb4t
cells and he mixed them
um with the car t cells or ontario two
cells
uh overnight and looking to see
could we clear this infection so you can
see with untransduced cells we don't see
any change
but at a four to one ratio using
the car t cell we see quite a
significant removal of the cells
and then as we reduce the
affected target ratio we see less and
then he was able to quantify this over a
range
showing that these t cells are effective
in um removing the the
uh hiv effect themselves um
and then a similar assay although
a little uh different is here we
measured
the amount of cost base three activity
in the target cell so we
we gated uh uh you know
away from the cards and looked to see
are we seeing
active killing in the target cell you
can see
um you know there's not that much cash
based reactivity
in the absence of car t cells but when
we mix the car t cells at a high vector
ratio
we see that a lot of them are actually
using
uh cat space three and again here we're
quantifying this
but i just wanted to point out that the
cba t cells with the 401 b
are roughly the same range as the cb4
cells expressing the cd28 customizatory
grains
now if we compare the fours fairly the
eights do
work better than the fours
but with the optimal or at least a more
effective side of heaven
we get roughly the same level of killing
so this this suggests that cd4 styles
in addition to their helper function
actually retained pretty good
cytolytic ability that's roughly
twofold less than uh cva t cells
and so again to sort of uh further
investigate this we want to look at the
ability
of uh cd4 cells to upregulate grandson
granzyme b as well as tnf and again this
also occurs in a constitutory
uh dependent manner whereas the forum b
signal or the 27th civil the
uh tnf family members are less
capable of upgrading this compared to
the cd28
and the cd3 zeta alone um
and then further looking at those we
looked at the ability to operate like cd
107 which is a regulation
that comes to the surface during the
green election so it's a marker
of killing potential uh
as well as the the
uh peripheral which actually puts the
holes into the cell so that they get in
and again cd4 cells were remarkably good
at doing this again not quite as
effective as the cd8 cells but
uh pretty pretty effective at uh
eliciting all the aspects of the killing
machinery
and then the the last study i'll go
through
uh it was the viva study
where we uh in this particular study we
just used cd4 t
cells expressing the cd4 car uh very
similar to the study we did with td8
cells
where we got cells infected
um you know these because of proper host
disease these tend to be very
short-lived studies so the
you know the art was only present for
four days uh
before we uh put the car t cells in
and then asked uh we eventually looked
at the ability of the car t cells to
expand
as well as the viral load um
and so we'll first look at the viral
load uh
again initially there's not that much
fire load because the virus is still
rebounding but a week after that
we started seeing significant levels of
viral load and some differences
now um what was
maybe somewhat perplexing to us is that
the t
cells that have the least functional
capability
actually uh maintain the lowest viral
load
whereas the cells with the highest
killing
ability the cd3 and the 28
the c3 doing the worst the 28 not doing
as well as the forward b
and then eventually um it kind of fell
out of flavor as well
and so this paradox could be explained a
little bit by just looking at the car
t-cell expansion
uh in this model so you can see that the
401b
we compare everything to the c3 zeta we
see
much more expansion of these t-cells in
vivo
relative to the cd3 or the cd-28
um and so what this tells us is that
maybe this part
it's better to have more t cells with
less
uh satellite potential than it is to
have less t
cells that are really good killers
um and then the the last well actually
one more time for this
so we you know again look at this uh you
know
just by flow because we've marked the
cells you can see uh
this is a point that's 12 days you can
see
how many more car t cells are present
with foreign b
relative to the other customatory
molecules again
this is quantified by this
we did look at exhaustion markers um
again the
the the cars with
the cd28 family members express higher
levels of these
uh exhaustion members than those with
the four of b ox 40.
suggesting that maybe these cells are
able to maintain the function longer
than these cells in an imbibo setting
and then the last study we did is a
little bit complicated but
we wanted to ask can the cd4 cells
actually help the cd8 cells
and so in this experiment we have a
controlled
cell here but here we have the cd8
car t cells um mixed with cd28 and again
uh these cells didn't work all that well
in gilo beforehand
but we we put those in there now we put
it
half as many of these cells
here and then with the other half of the
car t cells we added in the cb441 b
cells so there's a total of 2.5
million effectors but this one has a
mixture of cd4 and cb8
and this just has the cd8 cells
and what you can see is early we don't
see much differences
but uh later in the infection i think
it's like five weeks
we see we do see some expansion of the
cva t cells
but we see much more robust expansion
when there's a mixture and again
these cells were started out of half as
much as these cells so
the overall expansion is even more
impressive here um
and then we see as ceo created not a
massive difference in the viral load but
we do see that
the mice here had lower levels of viral
compared to these fights here
suggest that in addition to their
killing activity the cd4 t cells are
actually able to augment the activity of
the cd8 cells
and so on that i'll stop you know most
of these studies
again were driven by uh phenomenal
graduation kobe badini
with help from rachel levin to the thing
uh
kevin gail was a attack in the lab that
helped kobe quite a bit
um we got great support from our animal
facility corps
uh as well as the human immunology corps
and the clinical trial i told you about
was
the ti with pablo tibos with the
help from actually the entire center for
celebration therapy
then in particular julie davoski and pam
shaw um
and sangamot again provided the thing
figure
nucleases to us and on that i will stop
thank you for a great presentation i
would now like to introduce our second
speaker dr
andrea love she is a senior business
development manager here at nexlum
and one of our most requested speakers
for a complete biography on doctor love
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr love you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you um for the
introduction lisa and thank you so much
jim for that really excellent
presentation
um i know i have lots of questions um
but i'll i'll start off by giving my my
little talk as well
so um you know jim gave a really great
introduction
for what i'm going to focus on which is
really addressing some of these in vitro
analysis needs
when you're dealing with cell therapy
research and development
and so i'm going to provide a brief
overview of some of the challenges with
immunotherapy
and that's going to be the case for both
viral based immunotherapy and the
context of hiv as jim talked about but
also cancer immunotherapy and even some
disease states such as autoimmunity
um talk a little bit about using
image-based platforms for cell-based
assays in that context and then
really dive into some data to really um
differentiate some of these assays that
you can conduct
so immunotherapy is a very broad
terminology for a diverse class of
therapeutic modalities
it refers to of course adoptive cell
transfer based therapies so these would
be
categorized as cell therapies in the
immunotherapy context
those would be your car t based
therapies and as jim had described
you know cars can be cd4 t cells or cd8
t
cells have a variety of co-stimulatory
molecules
we also have adoptive cell transfer for
things like car and k
cells as well as other sorts of cell
therapy products like tcr-based t
cells ultimately these cells are going
to be targeted against a particular
antigen on a target cell of interest and
ultimately directed to
illicit cell killing or eradication of
those target cells
we have other non-cell immunotherapies
such as bispecific antibodies that serve
as a bridge between a target cell and an
immune
cell we also have tumor targeting
monoclonal antibodies
and we also have other sorts of uh
generic or agnostic therapies such as
checkpoint inhibitors
or um cytokines or cytokine receptor
inhibitors that
provide immunomodulatory impacts
ultimately the challenge is for cell
therapy
efficacy whether it's the case of
targeting or trafficking to a tumor or
targeting or trafficking to
virally infected cells as in the case of
hiv
is that you um you have to deal with
potential toxicity of the cars
themselves
you have to ensure that you can actually
traffic those cars or those cells that
are targeted against that
target cell to the particular location
in the body
and you also have to deal with a lot of
immunosuppressive factors in the body so
you have things such as
down regulation of the antigen of
interest which means that the car will
not be appropriately directed to those
cells
you have other sorts of
immunosuppressive secreted factors such
as
reactive oxygen species and then of
course you have
things that are going to be secreted
from the target cells themselves
so ultimately there's a lot of barriers
that
in a patient in a human becomes very
problematic to overcome
so in order to appropriately direct
research
and development methods we obviously
have a lot of those challenges that we
have to
um address so of course we have to be
able to identify and characterize new
targets for cell therapy
that includes high throughput phenotypic
as well as functional assays so we need
to make sure that
those cell therapy those cell products
are expressing
the receptor of interest they're
targeting the appropriate antigen
um that they're actually doing what
they're supposed to be doing so they're
actually killing those cells
and if and of course when we're dealing
with clinical product
we have to also make sure that those
samples are healthy they're viable
they're active um you know we have to
make sure that we adjust dosage properly
so we have to be able to count them
and then of course when we're doing
pre-clinical and even clinical research
we have to make sure that
those cell products um are highly
specific for the target of interest
so that means reducing off target
effects making sure that we're not
non-specifically killing other cells in
the patient or killing other cells in
the cell culture
and of course when we're dealing in the
context of tumor immunotherapy
um for many solid tumors we have to of
course
model three-dimensional cell culture
models to
appropriately mirror the tumor micro
environment and that includes
um you know prolonging the health and
the persistence of these immune cells so
we don't see
exhaustion and ultimately loss of
efficacy
so traditional cell-based assay
technologies utilize things like flow
cytometry
where you have a sample that you've
harvested you run through
a flow cytometer meaning a fluidic
sheath with a laser detection platform
and you calculate your data as a
function of scatter plots
um where each dot represents an object
of interest or an event
um of course limitations to that become
um
you know it doesn't work that well with
adherence cells it can be very time
consuming to process samples if you're
dealing with 3d architecture of course
you lose that spatial integrity
um so that's where something like a
microscope would come in which can
maintain that three-dimensional
architecture
but of course that can be very time
intensive
um another alternative be something like
a plate reader a fluorescent or a
luminescent
base plate reader which are going to
capture data very quickly
but again it's only reporting well level
data so you can't normalize too well to
well variations within a cohort of
samples
so nexalon enables you to overcome some
of those
roadblocks by being able to do cell
level and cell-based analyses
so we're a global company we have a
variety of families of instruments
that are really all designed for
image-based
cell analysis they all have distinct
roles within the lab and of course all
of our team of scientists across the
the world can really address and answer
those questions for you
the first roadblock is really dealing
with a lot of these primary samples and
so this is where the celica mx would
come into play
so when you're dealing with pre-clinical
animal or human
research or even clinical research often
you have cell counting bottlenecks
as jim mentioned you're dealing with a
lot of these different constructs
where you have different co-stimulatory
cars that you're testing for efficacy
and potency
and production of inflammatory cytokines
so you're often dealing with large
amounts of samples so the celica enables
you to count
in high throughput up to 24 samples in
two and a half minutes or less
to export things like viability cell
concentration
and things like gfp expression this
enables you to address those cell
challenges in those complex pre-clinical
and clinical research models so
in the context of car isolation
primary sample isolation car programming
and and t cell expansion you can utilize
this through every step
including assessing the count and
viability of whole blood samples
and that's going to be true for mouse
preclinical samples
patient biopsies whether they're liquid
or solid tumors
patient-derived organoids as well as
when you're handling large numbers of
samples
such as when you're processing cell
therapy products or dealing with even
mouse preclinical samples
from there you can really step into the
realm of image psychometry which enables
you to quantify images to produce cell
level
data in a kinetic as well as endpoint
basis
by being able to image whole well format
in a variety of in vitro cell culture
models
you can quantify cell level data without
having to harvest or trypsinize or even
trypsinize adherence samples
so utilizing this approach we use the
seligo which has a five
imaging platform five channels
brightfield and four fluorescent colors
and it enables you to image and quantify
whole well format from any plate format
from a six well plate
all the way up to a 1536 well plate and
that includes in all five imaging
channels
representative time to scan is shown in
that box in the bottom right there but
it's going to be on the scale of
minutes and that includes for any plate
format um and we also have adapters for
some flasks and other vessels
what this enables you to do is get very
flat illumination all the way to the
well edge which is going to be very
distinct from that of a conventional
microscope
to enable whole whole well and high
throughput imaging
even when you're assessing rare events
so when we're talking about these
functional applications the first thing
is looking at these cell therapy
products we want to make sure that these
immune cells are functional
that they're viable that they're
activated that they're proliferating
appropriately
so by utilizing the celigo you're
actually able to quantify and assess t
cell proliferation in a label-free
format so this is an image of a 96 well
you can see that red square is
indicating a zoomed in region
and the blue segmentation is denoting
the software identifying
these t cells that are quantified by the
the imager
it takes about six minutes to perform
imaging and analysis in a label-free
format using brightfield for a 96-well
plate and that's whole well imaging
utilizing this approach we have a very
broad dynamic range for t
cell counting so these are 120 000
cells per well all the way down to 8 000
cells per well
you can see the cells in bright field
there and the representative
segmentation
and taking this approach we actually
assess some of those
car constructs that jim had mentioned
with these different co-stimulatory
molecules
so we utilize the seligo to assess
kinetic proliferation
represented here as population doublings
for these different
car constructs that we were assessing
and as you can see here
we were able to quantify seven different
constructs over the course of a 10-day
growth
curve and quantify that in a very rapid
and high throughput fashion now of
course we do see some differential
proliferation rates
which jim actually uh mentioned during
his talk
based on the the presence of of a given
co-simulatory domain there
we also wanted to quantify whether or
not
the seligo could assess activation of
the t
cells as a function of area of the t
cell so as
t cells are naive or dormant essentially
they're going to be very small and
rested
but as they're activated they're
preparing for division they're producing
all sorts of
um you know cytokines and other sorts of
molecules
and so their area of the cells
themselves or the volume of those cells
will swell
and that tends to peak around six or
seven days after activation
to which point they then start to rest
in a somewhat smaller state
um so we utilize the seligo here you can
see these images these are the same
scale at day zero day six and day ten of
this t-cell activation
um screen and you can see even just by
eye that the t-cells are visibly larger
at day six
compared to day zero and then somewhat
smaller by day ten
we actually then plotted that as a
function of the the um
surface area of the t cells or the uh
sorry the cross-sectional area of the t
cells here and you can see that even
amongst the different
um constructs that were tested you see
that very similar trend that they
started a very small resting size
they increase in size to peak around day
six
and then they actually reduce in size as
they return to a somewhat rested stage
so this is a nice indication of
monitoring activation of these t
cells in question in addition to looking
for things like proliferation as a
function of number of cells over time
and
activation as a function of size you can
also utilize the fluorescence
capabilities to assess things like
viability or apoptosis of these cell
therapy or patient products
so here we've got three images depicting
aopi based fluorescence viability
so your green cells are viable cells
your red cells are dead cells
and then non-fluorescent objects are a
nucleated debris so those could be
things like residual red blood cells or
platelets in your pbmcs
and then in your t cell expansion image
there
you can have some tissue debris
especially in the later stage of
expansion
you can couple viability with something
like apoptosis markers as you see in the
right hand panel of four images
where we look at things like caspase-37
activation
which will fluoresce in green in cells
that have initiated the caspase cascade
and then of course burpidium iodide
positive cells where
now they have a compromised membrane are
closer to true
cell death finally you can also couple
that with true markers of activation so
here we did immunofluorescence-based
staining for cd69 for activation
in cd4 and cd8 t cells so we have cd4
lex 488 cd8pe
and then cd69647 we use hooks as a
counter stain there and then quantified
the proportion of activated t
cells as a function of um different
stimulation of these populations
so once you've been able to characterize
your t cell products or your cell
therapy products you know that you're
they're activated they're proliferating
they're viable then of course we need to
assess potency of them
so there's a variety of different direct
cell killing methods
to assess potency or in vitro efficacy
of these cell therapy products
ultimately many of these have
limitations
a lot of them are indirect measurements
of cell death you have to have a lot of
internal normalization controls
or if you're using flow cytometry of
course we have to harvest those cells so
we're
limited as to being able to do kinetic
assays
so using the seligo you can actually
quantify cell-mediated lysis in a
high-throughput and direct
cell quantification method so by having
a fluorescently labeled target cell
population
you can quantify kinetically or end
point
in cell level data how many
target cells are killed over time or
under differential experimental
conditions
so here we're just showing we use
calcium am to label our
our target our target cells here these
are k562s
this is an example of a bulk pbmc
killing assay so the pbmcs are unlabeled
in bright fields
and then the segmentation is denoting
the identified
target cells that are viable so as those
targets are killed by the pbmcs
they will lose that green fluorescence
so we're able to actually quantify this
over time so we use again calcium am
labeled k562s as a target
cell here these images are captured at
four hours after adding effectors
um and then of course we actually added
il2 to prime those pbmc so you can see
that we have obviously a dose-dependent
effect based on e to t ratio but also an
effect based on the presence or absence
of il2
you can take this approach and expand
this to test different car
constructs so here we used cho cells
that were expressing
the antigen of interest so these were
engineered to express a given antigen
and we assess 11 different car
constructs
to assess viability or killing of those
cho cells
over an eight hour time course and of
course you can see that there is an
e to t dependent effects so higher e to
t ratio
you have more killing over time but you
also have some differential effects
based on the car
construct here and this enables you to
screen really rapidly
up to say 150 different test conditions
and 20 minutes or less
so taking that approach we actually
wanted to assess these hiv
cars of interest so here we have
those those cars that jim had previously
discussed
we have the on target k562s that are
expressing the hiv envelope protein and
then we have the off target k562 so
those are the k wild types
we have the the cars themselves so
they're transduced to express the car of
interest
and then of course we have untransduced
t cells so you can see
here that adding at higher e to t
dependent ratios you see
increased killing of these um target
k562s expressing the hiv
envelope protein you can see a loss of
those gfp expressing
k562 cells as a function of e to t ratio
of course we see little to no effect
with the untransduced conditions
you do see a little bit at the higher e
to t ratio with some off target killing
but again that that's not unexpected
the additional advantage is that it
enables you to do this kinetically
so we monitor these different um car
constructs over time over a 72 hour
killing curve
and on the very top panel you have just
the the on target gfp k562 so the k562
is expressing the hiv envelope protein
you have the second row is your on
target k562s with the untransduced t
cells and the bottom is with the actual
cars of interest and so as you can see
very clearly by eye
over time you see a very pronounced loss
of those viable k562s
only in the case of the co-culture with
the cars themselves
and in the other conditions you see
obviously a proliferation of those cells
over the 72-hour time course
the data again is plotted there you can
also use this to monitor combinatorial
approaches
so here we're looking at um checkpoint
inhibitor therapy so this is a different
type of immunotherapy
to assess the ability of this checkpoint
inhibitor therapy
um here it's a teslizumab which is a
pdl1 inhibitor
and then we used um chloroquine and
mg132
as monitoring the ability to augment t
cell-based cytotoxicity
and so here you can monitor the
significant reduction in the number of
viable target cells
in breast cancer cells here so this is a
cancer cell immunotherapy
both at 24 hours and at six hours um
with and without the augmenting
therapies here
so again these are all done in 2d
culture but another
um another interesting facet that you
might be able to
interrogate is doing a cold culture to
assess the specificity of an
immunotherapy
so another question is we want to ensure
that these cell therapy products are not
eliciting off-target killing
so here you can actually do a co-culture
with two different fluorescent reporter
cell lines
to monitor the specificity of your cell
therapy products
so here we have gfp expressing heck 293s
that are expressing the
antigen of interest and the other ones
are m cherry expressing hec293s that are
not expressing the antigen of interest
these are co-cultured at a ratio of one
to one so 50 50 in each well
and then we added six different car t
constructs at different e to t ratios
and we wanted to monitor specific t cell
killing
in a time dependent manner and this
actually also happened to be a cell
therapy for hiv
so it's a mbl uh manus binding lectin
and so here you can see your off target
cars uh your off target cells your m
chair expressing cells
over time you see no pronounced change
in the number of cells
with target alone versus with your cars
of interest
again these m chairs are not expressing
the antigen whereas with the gfp
target cells you see a very obvious
dose-dependent effect with
increasing proportions of car to target
cells
and obviously you have the most
pronounced reduction with your
one-to-one ratio
target alone looks very similar to um
you know what you would expect no no
off-target killing here
so by utilizing this image based method
you can actually assess
two independent differential populations
using the same test conditions without
having to have
different um different wells there and
then the last thing i really want to
dive into is just scaling this up to
look for 3d
cell culture models so taking those
approaches we utilize in 2d
and assessing 3d culture models in the
context of solid tumor therapies
so here's looking at an adcc based self
cell cytotoxicity assay
in a 3d spheroid model so that schematic
is just defining how we form these
spheroids in a u-bottom plate
so these are k-562 cells that we've
generated spheroids with
we've labeled with calcine am as a
marker for viability
and then we looked at e to t dependent
ratio for nk
cell mediated killing and after four
hours you can see
very obviously a loss of viability
particularly at the
exterior of the spheroid particularly
with your higher edt dependent ratios
and that's in contrast to your negative
control wells there
you can also assess things like t cell
based killing this is a bi-specific
based immunotherapy so imtac is a bridge
between cd3 on a t cell
and then hla peptide on a cancer cell of
interest
um so adding intact should in theory
prime those t cells to illicit cell
killing of the target cells
so these are gfp expressing spheroids
you see
almost no loss of viability with
obviously target only so just the
spheroid
but with just t cells and targets you
don't see a pronounced effect
as you start to add intact with the
effectors and the targets
you start to see not only a loss of the
gfp expression as those target cells are
killed
but also a dissolution of the size and
integrity of the spheroid
and finally you can scale that up to
patient-derived organoids where you can
actually assess these in a more
physiologically relevant solid tumor
model so these are colorectal cancer
organoids
we're looking at a bi-specific antibody
therapy called sibysatomab
which is targeting cea antigen on
colorectal cancer
so these pdos were scored based on the
expression baseline expression of the
antigen of interest of cea
and then we assessed the efficacy of the
t cells to
kill those organoids uh with the sibisab
map treatment
so colorectal cancer organoids that
had high levels of cea expression so
very very pronounced um oops
very pronounced edt dependent um killing
of the organoid tissue
particularly when compared to your
untargeted control antibody
um we did not see that effect with just
the t cells themselves
it was only upon addition of the
sibisadamab to
act as a bridge there we did not see
that effect when we looked at organoids
with low expression of
cea or in organoid culture that had
mixed or intermediate levels of cea
expression
so again this enables us to utilize this
as a screening tool
for more personalized medicine
therapeutic modalities
we do have a broad variety of
publications that use seligo for these
immunotherapy type assays including
one for hiv that that i presented some
data on just now
um of course of broad variety for other
sorts of immunotherapies
um we're happy to send those
publications along to anybody
and i think now is a great time to take
any questions anybody has
thanks andrea and thanks dr riley
now it's time for you to enter questions
into the chat box
and we'll just give it a second here uh
andrea you had mentioned
at the end of dr riley's talk that you
possibly had some questions for
him and while we wait for people to ask
questions
is there something you'd like to mention
with to him sure jim i was wondering
um you know i know that you've you've
mentioned and we've observed that we do
have differential proliferation
of those cars with the different
co-stimulatory molecules
do you have a mechanism at as to what
might account for that differential
proliferation is it simply just some of
the intracellular signaling that you
would expect
um we don't have a complete answer but
certainly
the 401 b signal definitely gives a
survival advantage so
again cell growth is a combination of
cell division
you know burst cell death and so if the
cells aren't dying as rapidly
it looks like they're growing faster um
so that's certainly the case there and
then
for the cd28 we think that signal
terminally differentiates the cell
so that they um you know sort of lose
their peripheral capability
um in a short like weak acid you don't
see
it that pronounced but in the amiibo
studies that's where you really see um
the effect of cb28 okay great
thank you um and and when you're looking
at some of these because
because i know you had mentioned that
what was somewhat counterintuitive was
that the ones that
seem to elicit lower cytokine profiles
and correct me if i
i interpreted that wrong but lower
inflammatory cytokine profiles actually
seem to fare better in the in vivo model
is that what you guys had observed
right right just because those cells
proliferated to a much
you know higher level so you know they
became you know 10 to 100
to 1 versus cd28 so
it ended up being cells with less
capability actually control the
replication better because there were
just a lot more of them
gotcha okay that makes sense
okay so i have a question uh can you
measure t
cell proliferation while doing the 3d
based adcc
oh that's a great question so it would
depend a little bit on
how you're setting up your assay so in a
u-bottom plate if you have if you're
generating a single spheroid and a
u-bottom plate
it's going to be very challenging to see
kind of the individual t
cells because of course you have a
rounded bottom
however if you're interested more in
something like
t cell proliferation and expansion in
the context of a culture model like that
then you could transfer those spheroids
to something like a flat bottom plate
and you would have a greater likelihood
of being able to assess t
cell proliferation for something like
that um
i may recommend using a fluorescent
reporter like a cfse or something like
that to label the t
cells because then what you can actually
do is you can
gate out any debris from the spheroid
that might be
um you know perturbing your ability to
image and quantify the t cells
themselves
okay great the next question i have is
how do you best measure t
cell proliferation and activation
oh well that's a good question um i
think that's going to be somewhat
dependent on
what your assay is dictating
um again you know as we've worked with
with jim's group and with a few others
we do that in a label-free format we're
looking at both just
number of number of cells over time
as well as the size the change in size
over time as they become activated
however if you're doing that in a
co-culture system
or if you're looking to assess a really
definitive
indicator of activation then of course
you have a variety of different markers
that you can do immunofluorescence-based
staining to assess them
okay i have a question for dr riley if
there is a constant pressure
on hiv to mutate as you showed in the
first set of clinical
data do you see most therapies continue
to chase the next mutation if cd8
receptor on cd4 showed similar killing
why you see b4 on a cd4 t cell
you have to get to the last one there
but yeah i mean so the
the reason we use cd4 you know
most car constructs use a single chain
antibody
to retarget the t cells and you
certainly can do that for hiv
the the problem there is that hiv
envelope
is highly mutatable so you have to then
use a
pretty large cocktail of car t cells to
sort of get the same effect
um by using cd4 itself um
we hypothesized that if hiv was to
escape
from binding to cb4 then it just would
it would lose a lot of its potency
wouldn't be infectious
and so uh that was you know for a
firstly human trial it's better to have
one product and that's why we chose to
use cd4
but i didn't quite get the one further
question so maybe
rephrase that or the first question
the second part of the second part if
cd8 receptor on cd4 showed similar
killing
why use cd4 on a cd4 t cell right
because uh killing is not everything
that you need um
you know cd4 cells play a huge role in
terms of
um you know providing cycle signals to
the c8 cells to
uh il2 il21 the
cd4 cells can also then help with your
b-cell response
and help regenerate and maybe help you
develop neutralize the antibodies more
so
um yeah ideally you would want to put
both
cell types in but i think if i only had
you know if someone said you could only
put one in
i'd rather just put a cd4 cell because i
think it's going to do more for your
immune system than the cd8s would
okay and the first part of that question
was um
is there a constant pressure on hiv to
mutate
as you showed in the first set of
clinical data do you see
most therapies continue to chase the
next mutation
right i mean at some point i mean
certainly what the
the drug therapies tell us is that if
you have three separate pressures on hiv
that it can't usually escape all three
at the same time and i
i think for cure studies that's probably
where we're going to end up i think
we'll need some combination of t
cells you know broadly utilizing
antibodies and k cells perhaps
but you know giving one
one therapy at a time generally hiv can
get around that and so i think that's
why
combination therapy is gonna be required
to you know enable a cure strategy
okay uh was there differences in some
type of t
cells like in may bodies t
cells versus effector t cells regarding
proliferation and activation
in hiv patients
um so so in the studies we did we just
used
total bulk cells that you know so
they're a mixture of uh
you know central memory naive cells uh
and so within those population there are
huge differences in terms of their
ability to expand excited kinds and kill
in that particular study we didn't
really tease that apart
uh sort of under the the idea is that we
really want to put all these types of
t-cells back into somebody because
each have their own little niche in the
immune system so the more we
reconstitute that the better
and another question have either of you
run into issues regarding preserving
these cells for the live cell assays
um i mean for some of the athletes you
could do
i mean you can't use side of the reserve
i mean
maybe just angry but for for us we we
find that we can use side of preserved
uh
uh cells for many of these assays
yeah and and you know i think i think
that question really depends again on
the cell culture model you know certain
primary cells are going to be a little
more fragile and you're going to have to
handle them
you know more carefully whereas if
you're dealing with a stable cell line
that's of course going to be more robust
and you know be able to be perturbed
more
um you know for some of these killing
assays that i was showing data from
um you know we're working with an
engineered k562 cell line that's
you know stably expressing gfp and the
hiv envelope protein
and and granted while those are you know
primary expanded t
cells they are healthily maintained in
culture until we added them
to the coal culture um so i think
keeping in mind
what your cell culture in vitro assay
is and what your model is can really
dictate or direct how you have to handle
them
okay and i have what looks like one last
question
what if my target cells don't have
fluorescent protein expression
how do i measure cytotoxicity that's a
great question
and i think something that comes up
pretty pretty frequently so
um you know obviously a a fluorescent
protein expressing
cell target cell is is the easiest to
work with in the context of quantifying
um killing over time but there are a few
other methods that you can employ
some of that's going to depend on the
time course for your killing so for t
cell killing assays we
were as you probably noticed we're
conducting those over the course of
several days
so if you didn't have a fluorescent
protein expressing cell line then you
can use cell tracker dyes like a cell
trace violet or
cmfda in combination with a viability
stain we often use pi
or nexon actually have a whole
array of viability stains that are
compatible with celigo that we
created protocols for if it's a shorter
term killing assay like an nk-based
killing assay which
often um are completed within four hours
or so
you know certainly less than 24 hours
then you could use
other things like a calcine am which is
a similar viability or vitality reagent
or a calcium am violet as well so there
are a few different options out there
that you can utilize we even do have
some people that are doing
surface marker staining and live cell
culture so they can really differentiate
different cell populations in that mixed
culture
okay we've had some great questions i'd
like to thank dr riley and dr love for
their presentations today
and i'd like to thank all of our
attendees for taking time to attend
today's presentation
if you have any additional questions you
can submit them
through the ask a specialist
booth at the event we do ask that you
complete a short
survey at the close of this webinar your
thoughts and comments would be greatly
appreciated
make sure you visit the poster hall and
exhibit booths where you can learn more
about a variety
of exciting technologies including some
of the ones shared during today's
presentation
this presentation was recorded and will
be available to view on demand
until next time have a great day